The human mind sees faces everywhere.
They're very important to our societies.
We need to be able to recognize each other,...
...be able to tell who's a stranger, who our friends are.
My background is in psychology, particularly cognitive psychology.
I'm fascinated by the way that the human mind works.
How we can remember information, remember events, remember people.
If you think about it, when you see face recognition on the television or in newspapers,...
...it tends to be to do with police investigations.
Cognitive psychologists have discovered that humans don't recognize faces by looking at individual features.
One of the driving things for myself and my colleagues was to produce a much better match for human cognition.
The result of this collaborative project is a new facial compositing system,...
...which is being marketed internationally, which is currently in use by several UK police forces.
'Cause you're always working with a full face,...
...the system produces a good likeness far, far more quickly,...
...leading to a significant increase in the amount of intelligence they can gather about a crime.